[Música]
hace tres meses nuestra permita su meca
dentro desde el patio a la casa con algo
que parecía una esponja blanca en el
hocico cuando se lo fui a quitar noté
para mí horror que era un pedazo de pan
baguette
o sea como entra un pedazo de pan a mi
casa
estoy segura de que muchos de ustedes si
no todos conocen a alguien con un
trastorno relacionado con el gluten
eso no iba ahí pero bueno
con el gluten verdad
sean honestos cuántos de ustedes han
pensado hay que cansar al bien esa vieja
que nunca puede comer nada
a verdad los conos
bueno para personas con trastornos
relacionados con el gluten como yo cosas
tan mundanas como que entre un pedazo de
pan a la casa puede ser razón para que
entremos en modo alerta 'amarilla'
la versión más nociva de esta proteína
encontrada en el trigo la cebada y el
centeno y en todos los productos hechos
a base de estos granos pueden causar
estragos en nuestro sistema e impactar
nuestra calidad de vida e inclusive
aislarnos socialmente
con todos los avances que ha habido en
este tema porque ciertamente los ha
habido todavía me topo con situaciones
en donde rige la desinformación
incluyendo de que esto el gluten es una
moda y terminamos entonces siendo
catalogadas como personas locas
exageradas iglesias
de hecho me han pasado tantos chascos
con este estilo de vida que comencé a
escribir mis anécdotas en un blog
llamado blood aventuras
en donde le di vida al gluten con este
personaje verde lo bauticé blood y no
noten que aglutinó en forma de una orona
de pan es lo suficiente para
desencadenar una serie de daños que nos
pueden afectar hasta por meses y si el
consume es habitual toda una vida
se calcula que el 30 por ciento de la
población tiene trastornos relacionados
con el gluten la mayoría es más probable
que se le dé a las mujeres y por muchos
años en algunas personas puede pasar
desapercibido
y quiero aclarar que aunque ciertamente
los síntomas más comunes son los
digestivos o los más reconocidos tal vez
es un mito de que sean los únicos en
personas sensibles todos los órganos
pueden ser afectados cuántos de ustedes
conocen a alguien que se pasa que
dejando diariamente de algún malestar
será que evitando el gluten podrían
sentirse mejor
les cuento que yo presento síntomas
desde los 15 años pasé por varios
médicos generales y por lo menos 6
gastroenterólogos antes de dar con un
diagnóstico 17 años después y todo ese
tiempo mi cuerpo había estado
deteriorándose de forma progresiva
en los últimos años sentirme mal
diariamente era la norma
nunca quiero tener que volver a pasar
por eso y menos menos experimentar todos
los posibles síntomas y enfermedades que
se hace que se asocian a una
intoxicación con gluten que dicho sea de
paso son un montón
la instrucción que los médicos nos dan
después de nuestro diagnóstico es usted
debe dejar de comer gluten
inmediatamente por el resto de su vida
llama mitad yo me la acompañe
verdad y ahí voy yo al supermercado en
donde glut y no me aparecen
absolutamente todos los pasillos no sólo
en los lugares obvios sino también en
productos que parecen inofensivos como
salsa de soya y maquillaje
o en restaurantes en donde glut y no
vuela y salta en forma de bolas de pan y
partículas de harina
encima de esto
con la seguridad que da la ignorancia me
han ofrecido bocadillos aptos para mí
porque están hechos con splenda con
grano entero porque son vegetarianos
me han dicho que un jamón es seguro
porque cuando uno le rebana el gluten se
le sale
también me han dicho tranquila que en
este restaurante todo se cocina muy bien
y el gluten se quema
pero hoy
hay que tener algo muy claro aglutinó no
lo podemos matar ni neutralizar porque
él es literalmente como el chop noris de
las proteínas o sea no podemos servir
cortar inclusive lo podemos desinfectar
que esté mal no se muere y si nos
creemos las historias y nos comemos esos
bocadillos o nos comemos productos con
ingredientes dudosos pues entonces vamos
a pagar las consecuencias
los síntomas más comunes en mí por lo
menos los visibles
son unos que no voy a mencionar que
después la fatiga crónica y la
distensión abdominal
tienen que montón de veces me han dicho
hay felicidad es cuando enlace
y yo ahí o sea de verdad pasando
vergüenzas aclarando de que no hay sabe
que es que es pura inflamación
efe
y ha pasado bastante
pero no se imaginan lo que es viajar
para el trabajo
hace unos años ordene y confirme comida
especial sin gluten para un vuelo en
donde simplemente no me lo contaron
era un vuelo transatlántico de 9 horas
tenía dos opciones un ayuno forzoso o
comerme la comida que me estaban
ofreciendo y ganarme una tarjeta viajera
frecuente al servicio sanitario
claro a 35.000 pies sobre el nivel del
mar a mí se me comenzaron a salir las
lágrimas de hambre y frustración y para
echarle sal a la herida la gente del
pasillo del pasillo incluyendo el
sobrecargo me volvían a ver como si
estuviera loca porque claro para alguien
que no comprende la gravedad del asunto
es lo que parezco no me conozco
pero en el siguiente capítulo
qué es qué pasa qué hacemos entonces o
sea cómo se toma al gluten bueno
pues uno se arma para evitarlo a punta
de preparación estrategias y mucha paz
interior
como mi hermana y yo cuando vamos al
restaurante si usamos a nuestras parejas
como una barrera ante ellos sin
pedírselo mandan la canasta de pan de
vuelta evitan que las personas pongan
cosas con gluten o platos con gluten
cerca nuestro y uno de ellos nos da la
espalda mientras rompe el pan para
bloquear a las bolas que saltan
el apoyo de la familia es fundamental
porque ellos ayudan a alivianar la carga
física y también la emocional que en el
caso mío es lo más desgastante
no hay nada más lindo cuando le voy a
dar un beso a mi novio y él me quita la
cara y me dice no cuidado que me acabo
de tomar una cerveza
eso es amor
es amor
se acuerdan del vuelo y que no me lo
contaron y que lloré bueno eso ya nunca
me volvió a pasar porque ahora mis
maletas se desbordan con comida y es
mucho más rica que la que sirve en los
aviones
ya van dos veces que los pasajeros de al
lado me han dicho usted dónde se sacó
ese sanguchito tan rico y así es como me
preparo yo
pero bueno eso es para los viajes pero
para el día a día tengo un arma secreta
es un bolso mágico que le hace
competencia al de mary poppins bien de
aquí puede salir cualquier cosa
todos los días para mí son un picnic
a mí ya nada me avergüenza he sacado
comida hacen baby sabores y en
matrimonios
y sí
[Risas]
es una buena fuente de proteína que les
digo
bueno
se acuerdan de la historia de chueca con
el pan y mi reacción desmedida también
ahora tiene un poquito más de sentido de
verdad
en mi vida no hay campo para el gluten
así que la próxima vez que me vean
armada y peligrosa pregúntense de nuevo
realmente estoy tan loca
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]